[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I was about to say so brother blunder
what happened to our world and the [ __ ]
it ain't what was that it that's a crazy
move rook h1i you missed this regret
obviously I mean yeah why are we leaving
the a file we shouldn't be living the a
file
[Music]
[Music]
but I would very seriously consider the
move Bishop c4 followed by Bishop takes
of three and he seeks exactly just
saying
I will now oh you know all out play a
slab I don't really think this is a
grünfeld anymore and in these structures
this miss LightSquared Bishop is very
often the piece black worries about the
most because if you don't trade it for a
night for instance in particular of
course you would like to trade it for
the bishop on g2 but I don't think
anybody will let you do that so if you
don't trade it for the night and white
let's say if you play I mean the most
obvious example would be if you play six
which is maybe not such a stupid most
strategically you have to start what
we're wondering where this where this
Bishop is going now after h3
occasionally it starts running out of
squares and just in in more general a
sense if you want to play let's say e6
and then perhaps Queen e7 rook c6 or FC
8 that Bishop is is the one piece you
really don't need on the board because
it just kind of gets in the way which is
why I'm I'm very drawn to this idea of
just actually wasting to Tempe now to
trade it off for a knight exactly I
agree as well I mean the bishop tends to
be a little bit of the fifth wheel on
the I square and oh one thing I've
always like kind of worried about if I
play East 76th too early at night on h4
Knight goes to H for that as well yeah
yeah it's very much a problem so
something tends to be a little bit
off-centered there and by the way
feeling that I think intuiting and what
we've been discussing as Sasha did plate
Luciano
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the chasuble masters we are
in the final day of the quarter finals
let me introduce our panel
I'm your host yes or Sarah won on a
Rudolf hosting all of our social media
channels and grand master extraordinaire
analyst and commentator is just simply
brilliant Peter Svidler welcome to you
both an honor what's trend thank you
again as usual yes sir for the kind
words I'm thrilled to be here on day
three of our quarterfinals and welcome
all of you on Twitter YouTube and chess
24 I'll be monitoring those three chats
and bring you updates from our social
media as well as our learning moments of
each round learning moments talking
about death as usual grandmaster Peter
Svidler
how are you feeling Peter about today's
final day of the quarterfinals feeling
feeling good I'm very excited and
yesterday I felt we mentioned he Cara's
incredible resilience and his fighting
spirit and his general bounce back
ability one of my favorite long English
words in the pre-show but still winning
on demand against against ding and
particularly in the fashion that he won
after sort of dominating the the rapid
portion and then I'm making a somewhat
inexplicable mistake in a drone Rukh
ending losing that and then losing the
first blitz game with white I think very
very many people would have just been
very deflated by those events and would
have found it difficult honestly to to
play the the remaining blitz games with
any kind of energy and not Hikaru Hikaru
played a very very nice game with the
black pieces wallet on demand and then
proceeded to to win their mageddon game
so I was
once again very impressed by his play
yesterday but today is a fresh slate so
of course anything can happen but I
think he car probably starts as by far
the happy of the two absolutely thank
you for that Peter and again let me just
set the table for everybody today we
play our third and final day between
these two players
three of the four semi-finalists are
already into the semi finals there you
get a chance to look at the bracket the
winner of this match goes up against
Magnus Carlsen not the great reward
that's certainly getting to the
semi-finals is what everybody is
aspiring for and this particular
quarterfinals I want to say has a lot at
stake not just the prize money which is
actually quite substantial but on a
break it down for us why the winner of
this match in particular it's so
important for the players it is
extremely important for various reasons
the top four finishers of this event
will automatically qualify to the next
stage of the Magnus Carlsen Chester as
you can see after the chasuble Masters
the next event coming up in July is the
legends of chess and all the
semi-finalists from the chasuble masters
will automatically be participants of
the legends of chess event so that's one
very important price additional prize
for our top finishers as well as the
grand finale and the grand finale we'll
have of course the four winners of the -
cost and imitation of the Lindo recipe
challenge
chasuble masters and legends of chess
but in case a player wins more than one
event let's say Magnus Carlsen wins a
second one for instance since he still
has a chance of course to double it down
now in that case we have a scoring
system for finding the fourth
participant
the grand finale in August and as for
that standing so far the player that is
doing the best in the overall scoring is
he Karuna camera since he was the
runner-up involved the Magnus Carson
Invitational and the Lynne Doris Abbey
challenge so Hikaru has so far the best
chances but in case
Bingley Ryan wins today and now that
will give the Chinese Grandmaster really
good chances to so because of that
scoring system Hikaru ending have an
additional price to play for and that
could be a potential invitation to the
grand finale as well apart from the
legends of chess well thank you for that
explanation so a lot on the line
of course or players were eliminated in
the preliminaries they each got four
thousand four players are going to be
eliminated in the quarterfinals they'll
get eight thousand two players will be
eliminated in the semi-finals they'll
get 15 and then big money for our
overall winner and run around 150,000 in
total for prize money is what the
players are playing for in this chest
bowl Masters and a million dollars
overall prizes on the Magnus Carlsen
tour so a lot at stake today for the
players and the players will be playing
as usual for rapid games each rapid game
will feature 15 minutes per side plus 10
second bonus player needs to score two
and a half or possibly three points and
they will win this quarterfinals and
seed themselves into the semi finals
in case the matches are tied 2-2 after
for rapid games then the players will
play a pair of blitz games with a
five-minute +3 second time control and
should those still be tied after those a
single Armageddon the game the player
who gets black in the Armageddon game
will be the player who did what the
player who can choose which color they
want to get in the Armageddon
we'll be the player who ranked Hyatts
from the preliminaries so that is
setting the table now I want to just
bring in Peter a little bit more on this
one because winning on-demand theater is
one thing the winning with undemanding
two black pieces then winning on demand
with the white pieces which karo did
yesterday is simply extraordinary and
does that momentum carry over today
Peter well we'll see soon enough I guess
is is the correct answer here we we
don't really know what the the
psychological state of the players is
but it's very very difficult to imagine
cacao and not being extremely happy with
the way he he handled the pressure
yesterday after that very difficult
sequence of games four and five the
final rapid game and then the first
blitz game the final rapid game really
did seem like he was handling himself
very very well and then I guess just a
momentary lapse of concentration there
ended up costing him when draw and and
the victory in the set overall was very
much within his grasp and then he lost
that first bridge game in which he also
I think at some point must have been
doing quite well but he seems to be very
good at refocusing himself in a very
very short period of time because the
breaks between games here are 10 minutes
at most and I know from from my own
personal experience how difficult it is
to wipe the memory of the the poor game
you just played entirely from your mind
to be able to play the next one like a
human being I failed at that on a number
of occasions honestly and it's so
remarkable to see how well he karo deals
with that particular aspect of playing
high level chess
thank you Peter you and me both and over
to you on what's trending on our social
media
a lot of stranding as usual yesterday
was the birthday of one of our
participants a nice giri and first of
all of course he celebrated by winning
his match his semi-final match against
Alexander group that was the first step
and then he had this lovely birthday
celebration with his family his wife so
picogram Ashley and their baby boy
Daniel the 26th birthday of a nice giri
once again happy birthday to a niche I
think he made this birthday a very
special one by beating the three-time
world champion
Alex 10-degree second qualifying to the
semi-finals one person that also went on
to congratulate Anish was Magnus Carlsen
himself by highlighting and he duly
converted it talking about initiate game
2 against Greece shocked love the game
wonderful technique hashtag happy
birthday
hashtag no jinx so that was Magnus
Carlsen Street right after round two
between Aneesh and Alex and a Greek an
ish later on thanked Magnus for his kind
words by saying please keep up these
tweets sir they may bring you less likes
but it is better for the Karma hashtag
thanks I believe after that hashtag used
by Aneesh he did not notice that this
particular hash that comes with an emoji
so Enosh added afterwards law I don't
know why the heart emoji appeared in the
end I swear it wasn't me
hashtag awkward to which he got a couple
of responses as you can see also from
our author of yesterday grandmaster Alex
Chow Levitch pointing out that a niche
also mentioned he did sitting there and
waking up so there's a lot going on
outside the chessboard to the province
of
Aneesh and Magnus makes it to the media
as well this was laying on Watson Street
about an article that appeared in The
Indian Express about the better on the
280 characters on Twitter now these are
the updates from the
little Twitter war between the world
champion and then Italy we do enjoy
their banter and of course we will be
back with more updates not only on their
excellent tweeting skills but also on
their chess moves later on thank you the
bromance balloons eternal this is
fantastic but I also sorry Anna I wanted
to get one more one more thing from the
social media in our question of the day
everybody wants to win these chasuble
chess courses so you gotta tell them how
they can do it absolutely yes sir every
day we have a question for you guys
today's question is the following will
the quarantine hurt developing players
AJ no ot B Ches or help them there's
lots of time to study
tell us about your opinion by using the
hashtag study chest on Twitter to let us
know about your thoughts on this and
every day we do choose a tweet as the
winner that will receive the course of
the day yesterday's winner is Matthew
congratulations Matthew and his tweet
was about which is the hardest area of
chess to improve he said the hardest
areas to develop when trying to improve
at chess is improving your intuition
when it comes down to it sometimes you
just have to go with your intuition when
it's not possible to calculate every
variation strong players can just feel
it
hashtag study chest congratulations
again to Matthew and if you want to join
Matthew by winning also a chasuble
course then do answer today's question
on Twitter with the same hashtag study
chess thank you Anna for that
I'll retrospectively answer for myself
about what is the most difficult area of
chess to improve for me personally it
was and always will be the middle game
you can always work on your openings you
can always work on your end games
there's so many tools for those two
aspects of chess calculation you can
work I know how with studies how to
improve my
related ability instinct that's
interested but for me it was always the
middlegame that lists the top one you
wanted to improve your middle game
because then you can outplay your
opponent Peter your retrospective on
yesterday's question what was the
toughest part of chess for you to
improve that's that's always a difficult
one because they all do come very much
bundled together and it's I think
difficult to separate but I do remember
that when I sort of started playing in
the strong tournaments in my in my sort
of breakout period the in the mid
nineties when I my rating showed up and
I started getting invited to the good
round robins I grew up being almost
exclusively a dynamic player mainly I
think due to not having good opening
preparation I was brought up on somewhat
dodgy openings and that is a very sink
or swim type of upbringing because if
you don't learn quickly how to create
tactical problems for your opponent's
when when you're already much worse
let's say with with black in every
single game you you end up not scoring
very very many points and then I got to
the level where I pushing it bluntly I
was found out and I was I started
playing against people who I couldn't
really trick tactically anymore and they
would just absolutely destroy me in
positions requiring positional
understanding good technique you know
decent understanding of end games and
then I had to sort of make the not the
switch but I had to incorporate all that
and improve it all that more or less on
the go because I was a young and
promising player I wasn't going to
suddenly get disinvited from tournaments
but but the result started dropping off
and I think for me that transition from
somebody who could understand how to
attack from a reasonably early a
and nothing else pretty much to our
somewhat all-round player that I hope I
am I am today that that transition did
not come come easily for me absolutely
lots of challenges and over to you for
more social media updates I just wanted
to highlight in case I reviewers missed
it we do have every single day banter
blitz shows and yesterday on Anna's
Geary's birthday it was none other than
the world champion Magnus Carlsen who
was taking challenges on chest 24 so in
case you missed the live action do check
out the video on chest 24 the YouTube
channel it's not every day that you can
see the world champion of any sport or
any game speaking his mind and
explaining his thought process by
playing chess against our viewers today
during the day right before i broadcast
started it was the former women's world
champion who you fun taking on
challenges that was another another epic
show I was listening to you found myself
as my as my warm-up for today's
broadcast and today as you can see
highlighted already Monday
Vladislav Artemia will be taking on
challenges again then tomorrow we have
Alex and aggressive on Wednesday Tim
murajjab of and on Thursday Penta Lahari
Krishna so make sure you check out the
mental recessions and try to challenge
these amazing superstars obviously thank
you anna and of course those are for
premium members that you can become a
Premium Member you can get a 40%
discount on your membership and
challenge these great players big shout
out to who Yvonne I noticed as we were
just coming on was finishing her banter
bliss and she looked like she was having
a lot of fun nice to see who you fun
back in over the chessboard I want to
put it like that and also on I wanted to
say that we have a new sponsor in
accessible and accessible master
sponsors give me $150,000 a lot of
people
of course not too sure who is jessabelle
what is it that they do update our
viewers may be late to our broadcast
about Chester absolutely we are very
grateful for chasuble sponsorship and if
you don't know this company the platform
of chasuble was founded by David crema
Lee and Ches youtuber John Bartholomew
that I believe many of our viewers know
and follow and it started out with
David's a basically personal project of
improving his way of learning openings
he wanted to have an efficient way of
memorizing his openings by building an
algorithm that would help him practice
more the opening moves and variations
and based on that personal project from
2013
chasuble grew out as a pro from a
project to a company launched in 2016
and has become one of the pioneers as a
learning platform initially for opening
learning now it also covers of real
estate video games and M games and none
other than the world chess champion
Magnus Carlsen has courses on chess
about - as well as our crew I launched
the course in cyborg Anna and yes sir
and Peter are working on an upcoming
chasuble course - that is true indeed
and I think I'm behind you and Peter is
behind me in terms of getting our Chesil
courses published also I want to say a
little bit different about this
broadcast we want to make it more
educational a more fun more interactive
so that is why on it is our bridge you
have any questions or queries to our
saddles as well as the players we want
to get the players the winning players
on our broadcast to answer your
questions so make sure that in the chat
you inform Anna about what questions you
may have
I'd like to turn it over to Peter for a
second to say Peter for me in the first
two days that Carl in a ding were
playing against one another this London
system is black
with Bishop f5 and h6 black was scoring
really really well oops
and they're off beat her sorry they are
they are off and I noticed that I didn't
mean to interrupt you by him by suddenly
clicking on the diagram but this is I
kept on mentioning it for the first two
days that they played against each other
but I went through their games prior to
the show today and this is actually
going to be the first Catalan which is
quite interesting considering that I'm
pretty sure doing played the Catalan
against Hikaru in at least one of their
previous online online events this
season but ting doesn't go for the main
line I think they discussed the main
line previously at least in two games
maybe even three but think instead goes
for the move Queen b3 after Knight of
three castles a very very rare move I
will admit I know absolutely nothing
about Queen c2 I have some idea of Queen
b3 just no none whatsoever
you know but Hikaru does not seem
surprised and he blitz us out C 565
Queen takes d5 well logical continuation
I'm sure offering this trade of Queens
white takes on c5 and Hikaru takes on B
3 and goes knight c6 so far so good
both of them appear to be reasonably
well booked up here which is not that
surprising in case of ding because
clearly there was his preparation for
today somewhat more surprised in case of
Hikaru not because he doesn't have
opening preparation but because as I
mentioned Queen b3 is a very very rare
move it's a I don't believe I've seen it
very much at all and you you normally
just don't expect this to happen but I
think what Hikaru is doing is just
perfectly perfectly healthy and when you
said Peter that this was the first
cattle and for me that was a real
surprise oh he was like what really IV
because for me being where in has a very
deserved reputation as a darn good
Catalan player so it was like what has
he been doing
of what
yeah he played a couple of English
openings and also perhaps we would have
had Catalans but Hikaru in a number on a
number of occasions was in a must-win
situation with black so he played the
Dutch so perhaps those two games at
least those two games in which Chikara
played the Dutch against against thing
could have been Catalans if not the fact
that ding was leading in the set and
Hikaru did not feel like the Catalan
would offer him enough of a winning shot
which i think is extremely fair Catalan
against an experienced Catalan player is
going to give black close to no winning
chances whatsoever it's very very solid
at least out of the opening of course in
a blitz game you know the fact that it's
completely equal out of the opening is
less relevant because you still have to
play but it's understandable that he
hoped it for the match instead very good
and turning our attention to the
position at hand I mean I want to use
the open half open a file for the move
Knight d6 Peter but is that gonna bring
white any joy I'm not sure oh I've also
been looking at that but I think black
is reasonably comfortable here I I
suspect he is not he's not all that
worried the bishop one before is quite
it's quite a solidly placed piece we
don't really have much in a way of
prospects for this bishop on c1 and I
think white needs a couple of Tempe here
for any hopes for an advantage I don't
know if you let's say be 53 and black
needs to make some kind of a really
non-committal move maybe like I don't
know a six a six is not bad but I
suspect there might be sharper attempts
and maybe like let's say if we imagine
white going 95 and black actually
continuing to help him by chasing the
knight the good squares and then taking
this position I'm beginning to like for
right it's true it's probably still fine
for black with precise play but I'm
beginning to like this rook FC one will
actually create a threat and so on and
96 has been placed so we'll see I will
see for my assessment is correct
I will also mentioned that Knight xy8 is
not a given you you you can make an
argument for 94 I'm knocking attacking
the pawn on e5 I'm not sure if it's a
good argument but you can
an argument yeah yeah I had a kind of a
idea Xavier actually now I'm looking at
it 94 might simply be better there is a
line and talk about the material
imbalance that might occur after rookie
a I was going to mention that as well
it's very nice that you bring this up 98
we have this tactic of Knight takes e5
Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5 rukiye
five finish before and very importantly
I think the ship d6 is completely
unplayable because of who kept Devon and
because black does not have a lift for
his King he just loses material because
he cannot really keep the bishop on the
diagonal due to the back rank issues
therefore after bush before the skewer
more or less forces black to play 97 but
I couldn't quite come to a definitive
conclusion about this rook everyone
still looks very attractive black has
has but I think maybe rook e8 is fine I
thought like absolutely had to play a
six here to throw to stop rock please
rook takes d7 and after a six I was very
curious about them of Bishop h3
attacking the 927 and still keeping both
of black rooks on this hook on the four
be a diagonal so nice initiative but but
rook e8 might be good enough because I
think this force is white to take and
let's say we take on a7 blood goes
knight c6 this is probably a very
playable position for black but all of
this is now irrelevant because ding well
arel irrelevant or not that material
imbalance it because it just looked like
you're getting a rook and two ponds for
two minor pieces man I gotta tell you
that's a big controversy today I mean is
it always position specific in your mind
Peter or do you have I think I think
it's possible to draw some conclusions
like some things I think will hold true
regardless of what the position look
like for instance of one thing I always
try to to get across when I discuss in
games let's say like this one to come
back to or maybe
actually come back to this endgame I
think this one maybe it's not that
immediately obvious but generally
speaking end games with this with this
material imbalance are much better for
the side with the rook and pawns if it's
one rook against zero whereas two rooks
against one are generally quite good for
the pieces or at least better for the
pieces compared because I think it's
important that you have a look on the
board to counter at least some of the
activity your opponent's rook can
develop so if you imagine in this
position somehow let's say if this
happens okay I think white is instantly
slightly happier about life
this particular endgame is still not
good for white because one of his two
pawns that he has with the rook is a
doubled one on the B file which is
really not going anywhere but we if we
imagine this this pawn is not on b3 but
on c3 this one probably is slightly
better for white and let's say this one
I would say isn't but once again this is
a very very general thing which I do
believe to be true but well it has sort
of limited utility mainly you have to
look at do the light pieces have a good
school good stable squares to to occupy
how active other rogues do the rooks
have targets in a sense that other weak
bones to attack and so on other good
files for the rooks so you do have to
judge it on on a case by case that just
feels like an incredible educated
movement if you ask me folks current
position yeah we were here a moment ago
we were discussing this position and I
did play 786 here and not just because I
was looking for a passing move for black
but also I suspect it's hanging
I suspect you can take on a 7 if black
does absolutely nothing in this position
so it might be a relevant move we have
to discuss I'm still very tempted to to
go let's say Knight of 65 and try to
justify our play tactically but 95 might
just not work
yeah take a look at that pawn sacrifice
money apart apart from Bishop a7 I'm
also trying to calculate Knight takes I
don't think it quite works out after 93
9 take c6 Knight takes f1 sadly that
Bishop is still a life on sadly for
white I mean that Bishop is still alive
and we don't have the 97 checked active
so we have to take it and the knight
actually escapes and then I guess black
is reasonably happy with life I suspect
it probably ends up being close to
equality maybe even not that because we
we cannot take on a 7 because of rook c1
check and once again back rank and we
also I think cannot take on b7 how many
we can do maybe maybe this is how we
equalize with a couldn't be 7 because
Ruby 8 appears very strong but actually
roof takes a 7 defends everything but
yeah not probably white is not forced to
to play a line which appears to lead to
mass simplifications Bishop takes a 7 is
very critical now I was looking at
something like he 5 before here this is
how I was trying in my mind to justify
playing on 95 but this is very committal
because well I'm trying to plea for and
then perhaps supported it of 7 at 5
after let's say 95 or 94 but if that
doesn't work out for me somehow this for
this structure collapses I will have
given up a healthy pawn on a 7 for for
nothing so I'm really unsure about this
yeah the the play there doesn't look to
be enough 95 at the desirable 95 as you
say just might be unfortunately
unplayable the alternative I think you
mentioned the alternative right I think
yeah I think it's probably the move you
make if if you don't want to think too
much so to speak it's their
consideration for example b6 you
mentioned 95 and just because of being I
don't know double pawns after Knight d6
95 this let's say 94 just let's say I'm
groveling for draw and bishops of
opposite color
am i taking too many liberties I'm not
entirely sure this might be playable but
just on general grounds I really dislike
the idea of robbing my knight on c6 of
its support and b79 g5 is not for
something like rook FC one might happen
and he correctly goes for something very
concrete here his play d5 before a move
I considered but was very unsure if I
want to allow 95 because now this pawn
on e4 is under severe pressure I guess
he has calculated rook f8 and determined
that he will be able to fold it and ding
quite quickly agrees with him by playing
94 so could we just invest agait t'what
Hikaru might have been calculating ie
for Knight g5 Bishop a7 h6 I'm assuming
is what yeah and if you force white to
play Knight to h3 I assume you're not
that unhappy I don't quite know how he
was intending to continue here but it
really doesn't look all that threatening
we can maybe even afford to play g7 g5
here just to make sure that night
doesn't come back anytime soon and then
play for positional compensation main
aimed mainly at exploiting this really
horribly placed placed piece fair enough
I mean one bad piece in the position can
ruin the whole position so 94 wisdom
Lauren's choice
and Bishop c5 played very very quickly
by Hikaru also understandable because
after 94 we weren't definitely
threatening Knight takes and rook takes
a 7 and if you take on before your
entire position is now on fire Bishop
takes f6 Bishop takes c4 is a huge
threat a 7 is still hanging it's pretty
much unplayable I think you cannot you
cannot really afford to do that and
after Bishop c5 it's a lot a lot
healthier because I think making sure
that the pawn on e4 survives is
absolutely priority number one here for
black
yeah the pawn on e4 especially contains
that you will the
Siobhan Shih Tzu and had it candid being
a play for an advantage bill I'm I mean
the most direct way to continue here
with white is of course simply to take
on c6 intermission only three is
impossible because of 97 checks so we
have to take on c6 white takes on c5
takes on 87 I assume the plan here is to
play rugby 5 I'm not entirely sure but
that would be my initial reaction
probably kicker is intending to be 5 and
I'm looking in this position and I'm
trying to figure out what I think about
let's say rook FC one Ruby three rooks
it though because if you add two moves
to this position for white I think III
and h3 this might become somewhat
awkward for black because the pawn on e4
is a constant source of some worry maybe
not major worry but some worry let's say
let's just make a couple of passing
moves here yeah just to just to
illustrate what I mean if we have this
position on the board the rookin b3
looks quite beautiful but it's not
currently attacking anything and in
particular if I'm in time to play
beforehand Bishop c4 and then drive the
rook away from b3 perhaps play b3 myself
blacks position will require some
attention because he's a little bit tied
down to the protection of these sorry
these two these two pawns but because
obviously white will not be allowed to
make five moves in a row here some kind
of Ruby g8 D 1 B 1 count to play
probably can be could be quite strong
starting with row B g8 immediately and
threatening that incursion actually my
first impressionist things look a little
bit even Steven and the most direct
route but now having said that well I
don't see a real alternative for white
to this direct route yeah I think he's
gone for it I I assume because I mean
this is winning some material for now so
this must have been the first thing he
checked so the fact that he paused for
about three minutes considering I'm
guessing Knight a5 as a second second
option maybe
is the the obvious second option here
but he ends up still going exactly for
the position we discussed you can also
play row k3 now and say I am not obliged
to give back the b-pawn straight away
but black will develop a lot of counter
play here with either of d8 or perhaps
rook c8 is also playable let's say Ruby
atroxium on g6 or something like that
and then the rock lands either on d2 or
on d1 and starts creating issues now
that was a very important moment because
I always had a principle Peter you take
the last two rook moves back for just a
second if you go back to fly I
automatically as black want to play the
move rook c8 and then give my opponent
the D file I'll take this see pal I'll
give my opponent the D file and the
reason is is because the knight on that
six ever sees yeah yeah I think I agree
with you I think it's it's probably
healthier to do it this way and so just
being equal yeah just to make sure that
rook d7 is never is never a threat
yeah I would tend to agree with you here
and seeing as you can see has not played
row k3 yet so just rotate three in
principle looks kind of yeah I don't
know it's too defensive - well yeah -
defensive I liked your route c1 a moment
ago much better but I think the issue
with Devon would be one counter play is
quite significant let's say we go room
d8 here and let's say white plays I
don't know [ __ ] before nor h3 pick one
I like Bishop h3 actually do you measure
face three okay but yeah that is
actually quite clever with with those
intentions Yeah right and I'm thinking
that if I can get it it's really funny
good play move h6 just be cooperative
for a moment Bishop c8 and d6 be very
very very cooperative and now exactly
exactly
Bishop a6 and rooks
and you mention actually Bishop h6 is
maybe stronger yeah but why six with
that threat heads I'm just lining up for
that at seven on is really good for
white Peter this looks but interestingly
ding does go with the with the quieter
option of roxies or okay three and now
we will find out if if he car agrees
with you on the relative strength of d8
and see eight squares for the rook
because I expect the rook will go
somewhere here I don't think a waiting
will here makes much sense no so we'll
see we'll see which one he prefers I
think c8 is probably is probably better
I think I agree with you yeah okay well
let's assume rook c8 just for argument's
sake Peter what what would you do with
white would you feel number one do you
feel whites better at all or what's your
what's going on I think black probably
is fine because it's just difficult to
stop probably to comfortably we can play
rook Siwon and black does have to secure
his back rank here and by the way he
played room d8 I don't know why your
instinct turned out to be correct
by the way I've just been told but
unfortunately damn liran who is playing
from China has lost connection because
he has returned since
ok his his connection appears to be
appears to be once again of a source of
worry we'll be we'll be monitoring that
situation hoping that nothing really
happens rue k1 is a more like completely
missus it's very clever by doing and he
will now potentially have have time to
have time to Gore ok a trade one pair of
rooks and then come back to a three team
looking afraid I still want to play ok
aid and we munch munch munch munch King
is 7 I go back to a3 yeah but I suspect
something like Ruby g5 from d2 steel
equalizes somehow you also have the
option of having the King on c7 but I
don't think it's great because that if
in this position you
you ask why to trade on your terms and
play King e7 we can take bake I'll be
album I'm just not giving a check here I
think I'm going roughly three anyway
from I don't know if having it on d8 or
only seven is better for black I think
it's so once again it will end up
depending on precise calculations it's
difficult to judge on general grounds
I've always been how do you say charmed
I think that's a good word I've always
been charmed by really active King so in
that variation I was thinking that after
your rook a3 we traded rooks it was a
munch munch King
gingka zip its way to be four and maybe
tight white down someone do you know
what I mean I mean yeah I'm just uh I
don't disagree with you but he car
actually went the third way and just an
art King f8 all together and kept the
King on g7 so Hikaru doesn't really feel
like the King needs to go very far I
think he's and he would be the killer it
is so just for our audience when I was
suggesting to Peter like my my approach
might have been this exact position
except Black has a kingdom B for well I
mean the issue the issue with that yes
as you I'm sure well understand is that
no it doesn't actually have wings and it
would be illegal you stupid here so
it'll it would take like some time quite
some time to to get it even with the
help of King f8 and then king e7 and
would take him some time
and I probably we would be in time to
play something like III h3 Bishop f1
Bishop c4 and then you account the play
would I think they're actually this
might just be a drawn out of there
already repeating the car played rook c5
and after okay seven he played rugby
five a rook c5 and ding doesn't seem
very interested in trying not to play
okay seven in that position so you can
play something like once again
I know h3 rooks you one wish per f1 but
my suspicion is doing doesn't really
believe he is better here and I would
tend to agree with it because after
let's say 43
might regret playing for a win exactly I
get nervous as as white well
somebody who will most happily agree
with everything we say about Peter a big
shout out Thank You magnus carlsen we're
joining us hello hey but make your
fellow first what's up what's up no I'm
just just joining so I'm through the
same ones that would have what's
happened so far these two players one of
them is going to be your opponent in the
semis Magnus do you have any particular
preference as to who you'd like to play
I'd like to play the person who wins the
match that's that's my preference deep
thoughts man that's the sort of expert
commentary yeah works for ya we've come
to expect no no no grudge opponents huh
no I think either way they're extremely
strong and worried the opponents so I'm
fine either either way I'm just looking
forward to to an excellent match today
excellent Peter what's happening well he
Cara I think is I think if he goes rugby
five because Rho K 3 is more or less
completely forced rugby 5 is a draw it's
not just a draw for it is a draw because
Rho K 3 will be a three fold so I think
he car is trying to figure out if he is
better after obi-wan it it looks a bit
strange because black often in those
positions will be two pawns down but
maybe he can still try something like I
don't know in some order III and then 94
jump in yeah III then F three right yeah
the problem is f three cutting off all
the ways the knight can land on let's
say jakku which is the ideal square here
and here the plane Ruby five and the
game is already over so we're discussing
something that's no longer very relevant
so yeah I think III F 3 is a problem and
also Nagi
for just doesn't create enough threats
because we take and after III once again
a3 solves all of the immediate issues it
looks a bit weird to have this [ __ ]
point of one but black cannot really
attack it and we can start digging out
the III poem perhaps with rocky 7 well
you can go Knight age 2 and claim that
you have slightly the better side of a
draw but yeah that's that's fair
how do we make a precise draw here with
white by the way G for King G 3 yeah
yeah and then rookie 7 I guess you know
yeah that's that's going to be going to
be a draw so he carriages decides III
don't have much much over and also after
night before I guess we can go h3 and
not even allow any of that so that's
maybe a better option yeah Knight g4 is
nonsensical mm-hmm and yeah Ruby 5 for K
3 is just a 3-fold on the board so the
game gets terminated server side but
Anna I'm sure a lot of people in our
social media have some questions as
Magnus has joined us anything trending
Anna I think the most trending is usual
the bromance between madness and unease
so I'll need to ask for an update from
you my Magnus about the yesterday's
birthday celebration and your bender
procession tell us about your experience
playing against chests 24 premium
members it was fun lots lots of tough
games obviously but yeah I think there
there were some some some decent one
decent ones hopefully some instructional
value as well as a bit of flagging so I
think it was a good session anybody
anybody hold you to a draw Magnus oh
yeah the first the the last game I I
flagged my opponent with the King
against Queens that I was uh that was a
draw I should definitely should I lost
but there were also other games that
were very very close
uh-huh flagger is that is that the the
first game you ever not wandering a
banter session or no no I think I lost I
was 19 not plenty but a few I think at
some point you were on some kind of a
monstrous dry score against the server I
think maybe the first five sessions or
something I weigh what was scary to look
at
yeah but yeah now it's getting more
difficult really I needed a little break
I mean I feel like I've been there for
too long so when does the next game
start he's in seven minutes okay I'll be
back for that man all right like this
thank you very much we appreciate your
your being here
and everybody as we are going to just
take I believe a short break to get in
some commercial messages and we'll be
right back and catch on the other side
of the straight hello this is crystals
alaikum and welcome to my keep it simple
one default course
[Music]
hello this is Chris of delegate and
welcome to my keep it simple one efore
course
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Cara Juana
Alexander Chris Chuck and pent ala Hari
Krishna go premium at chess 24 to
challenge them and gain full access to
the world's most entertaining chess
platform
there are more moves in chess than atoms
in the universe
only one move ends again
[Music]
[Music]
my name is John Bartholomew and this is
the checkmate patterns manual hello
everyone and welcome back to the chest
bowl masters we're in a quarterfinals
day three of the match between you Cara
Nakamura and Daniel Aaron the first game
is drawn we're going to be playing for
rapid games board the first player to
score two and a half or three points
will decide the match but I know we're
very delighted to have a special guest
with us Christa Anat please make the
introductions for our audience
indeed we are thrilled to be joined by
international master Christopher lucky
who is one of the most successful
authors on chasuble it was our guest
earlier during the chasuble masters and
now he joins us to talk about another
course of his keep it simple with 1.d4
welcome to the show Christoph yeah hello
I know
greetings also to Peter and and yeah so
happy to be to be back and there was a
quite surprise said when I was just
about to join the call that Magnus was
coming on it was like oh what's going on
here and it was quite surprising so well
Christophe we wanted to make sure you
were in good company that was what that
was all about
again welcome welcome welcome and please
tell us about a little bit about your
course 1.d4 keep it simple yeah that
already am a typical Hollywood story
yeah the first book was kind of
successful so they wanted the second one
with almost the same name and we all
sequels nowadays and I've written keep
it simple efore in 2018 and 2019
it was the default version and in fact
the first game today we had a Catalan
opening and the Catalan is one of the
openings that I have in the book so what
I'm doing there is a d4 epitaph for
white of a full one you can basically
look up any possible black response and
I'm trying to suggest something
reasonable against everything it's
mostly based on
three system so it has the Catalan a g3
system against the Kings Indian things
like that so it's a I think a very
reasonable way to start 1.d4 and it's
all in one book so it's not like a huge
while you may not jessabelle
it is also video course so you can also
just watch the videos and learn
everything so great well it turns out
it's like 1.e4 and they're off for this
game to Peter take it away please
they are indeed off and they are
repeating a game they played yesterday
which ended up being a draw in a
somewhat dramatic fashion where with
both players seemingly agreed that the
game should be drawn because position is
so very equal
hikaru committed a very large mistake in
an equal position and ding for one-ply
was close to or perhaps just flat-out
winning but it did end up being a joy I
think it was Game two of the day
yesterday that featured that peace
sacrifice lots of pawns and that was
with a quick early f2f 4 which is the
same position Peter yeah I but but I
think ding played slightly differently
in that game I think I'm trying to
figure out how they got to how to how
they got to the position they got maybe
he played I think he played b6 there f4
champion himself again Magnus welcome
back to the broadcast
here Magnus
they're playing this variation of the
ante Berlin that's become very popular
your thoughts about this method for
white is he getting much play it seems
to me that in general ding understands
these positions very well I played I
played sort of a delayed really exchange
against thing in in Kolkata in in blitz
in
last year actually and my thought then
was that he would not be too familiar
with the structure since he does not
play the Berlin but actually played an
excellent game in one and it seems that
it ever since he has been very
comfortable in in these sorts of
positions I think the way that Dean
plays it
he doesn't make any particular attempt
at equalizing he just wants to get a
position and he feels that the that in
general he has good chances he doesn't
really care about whether you know he's
slightly better or slightly worse I
think nobody really really understands
understands that but he seems to play
these positions well and also yeah he
car goes for it time after time but it
feels like most most of the time being
placed these positions better thank you
for that
Peter jump right in and tell us what we
what we're staring at right now well we
actually had this discussion on areas
last night when in a similar position
you asked me if c3 follow perhaps by g4
was a good plan and I was not very
impressed then and I kind of remain not
particularly impressed now but maybe
after a six in particular it makes
slightly more sense to go for it Chikara
includes a waiting move in situ here not
pushing for d3 d4 straight away which is
a little bit interesting because it
allows like if he wants to play c5
getting well at least sort of making de
for slightly less potent arguably but
also I mean this is more flexible enough
to c5 maybe he car wants to switch back
to playing f4 so he is keeping both both
of those options open
we call in the game between them
yesterday worthy move F to F was played
acara then s a queen d1 to h5 which
maybe he regretted and brought his queen
back to f3 why is the queen so good on
c2 Peter
well mainly I think it's a decent
waiting move more than anything else you
connect your rooks you you are not
committing to either g4 or f4 for the
time being so you ask black to play
something which works well against both
and I don't know if Magnus will agree
with this or not I was too kind of on
the fence myself I was wondering if
after g4 dings intention was to take
they can play 96 which is sometimes what
black does in these types of structures
but specifically here I was not sure it
works out sort of move by move and one
reason why Queen c2 might be smart is
that one of the decent waiting moves
Black has here normally is the move b7
b6 to which we can now reply a reply g4
and say we have not allowed this 96 idea
at all so the night is still stuck on d7
in the way of blacks pieces but I think
that probably is a little bit too deep
honestly I don't I don't really believe
what I'm saying myself but I think
another thing that needs to be mentioned
is if white goes up for immediately then
EF for Bishop f4 night c5 is an issue
and obviously with the Queen on C - you
could go d4 here and not to Lizzy for it
so I think yeah Quincy - as you said isa
is a good waiting move for for a variety
of reasons really what I would consider
here though for black is to go night to
c5 and then if d4 I would just take it
if CED bring the night round - to b4
yeah that does and does workers actually
feel pretty pretty okay for black unless
Knight a5 somehow we're expected I don't
think with might be 7 or something but
it shouldn't work yeah but it's it
shouldn't yeah I don't I don't believe
this ever works out for write something
like d5 see denied b7 with the intention
of playing 95 but it's just like even
even d4 you wouldn't be unhappy as like
I think yeah 90 a bit should be 3 yeah
that's that's probably just excellent
for black that you take c3 following on
the next move
ding display b6 though not committing to
anything just yet yeah but perhaps b6 as
you said is more committal than it looks
since your car is now gone now Gandhi
for and okay it goes to be a it for the
Knights yeah that's sort of very similar
to what Magnus was describing but about
310 p2 to slower so yeah I shouldn't be
shouldn't be so unhappy about it here
doesn't this you know like Fisher random
no it's uh it's another one of those
somebody will not read this position
with the hashtag stay at home and will
will once again garner a lot of likes
and retweets yeah or deservedly well you
said fish random it's more it looks sort
of similar to an actual Fisher game
right when he used to play they exchange
did he have this structure against
purchased or somebody like that always
start with Bishop f3 I see that
Christoph is is nodding his head so I
could be right
yet this is a famous game yeah there was
I mean there there was this one where he
wants one against UN Sica but that was
with now I think there he just pushed up
for a five that was with a blanket plan
yeah I think yeah the cup of blanket
lands that was not with with CD I think
against partnership will see do but I
don't I don't fully remember well just
as you prescribed Magnus ding wherein
obviously with the move 97 to p8 was
rerouting his night before once that
night gets on before Peter though just
kinda feels like blacks position is like
super solid it should be six I like it I
like it for black Bishop e7 h p6 Bishop
f7 Queen g7 ro k g8 I think it will be
very very difficult for y2 to get
anything
anything going because you constantly
have to watch out for the fervor for
your Center
even if 6:05 eventually
what should really bring the knight to
g3 here I think just to cover cover the
DF v square and then it's sort of hard
to find a plan for sure
but I think that's that's a good good
way to good way to start but I in
general I would agree it up like us as
decent player well that's actually a
good question Magnus I mean here you
imagine you're sitting on the white side
of this position and you you know you're
an extremely active player you're
looking for an active plan
you mentioned Knight g3 what would be
your follow-up once you achieve that
though I don't know but first of all I
would like not to get hit by by f5
anytime soon and just have the center
collapse I see and also the night indeed
true very much was a superfluous Knights
mm-hmm
so that's one of the reasons yeah he got
started with b3 and now if the Queen d7
he will have to at least consider of six
or five I guess he can still go Knight a
phone because of 595 is currently not
that great appears she's just gone he's
just gonna f3 or you can imagine he he
wants instead Bishop F 293 and then 94
yeah that that could be another another
way to reposition any pieces but before
it could be hiding though yeah that's
and and dingos Queen f7 perhaps is f5 a
threat now probably still not a threat
right
is he intimating be five is a potential
threat that could be that could be
interesting in particular or the way the
pieces are positioned right now because
the knight will have to go to some do I
think chorus riff to which Purse to hell
should be but what do we think about
before anyway is it is it nothing to be
pretty happy to see it to me fair 93
yeah I mean only if it works somehow
works there now 92 c4
but yeah there are no jumps that I
particularly love here four-plex
I mean 95 85 I think Aida 5 just wins
here with the d6 and then EF is a threat
but even if I didn't have that I think
something like Queen Queen c2 O'Quinn d3
would be perfectly fine either
well Queens yeah I probably both are
fine yeah yeah because a5 is always
hanging and Bishop we have to of course
played by kicker because I we assume
that always has been part of the plan
here this was actually more probably
more fluid than the plan that I
suggested but I still feel like I should
put one of the rooks and e8 now just to
counter the plan midnight eats me
perhaps actually the e rope here because
yeah you want to you want to keep b5 as
not as an option as an option yeah and
after okie g8 it's actually not that
easy to make a move for white suddenly
and that's what he played yeah do we
have any I want to mention something
every day we want a like a instructive
moment of the day the learning moment of
the day and I'm happy to announce that
we have one and that it's an IPA in this
game
that'd be a it's a really cool idea that
it would not come naturally to I think
many players because the night is
already out on d7 but if you look
closely it doesn't do anything and then
you spot the before Square and say okay
it takes a while but once it's a it's
great so this is a really cool moment in
this game yeah I'm more familiar with
like this idea of karez that Tyrells had
this kind of structure with a pawn on e5
and then he played c6 epoch and then he
went Nikon d70 8 to c6 because the
knight on c6 was just a lot more active
than the night on d7 this 98 maneuvers
feels like it's well from the Slav
defense where you know you get this
diagram I'm really becoming very
interested by d5 here you know I think I
think we need to probably we need to go
back to 98 for
just for a second because it all looks
very good but let's say white comes that
for here I was wondering about that but
I don't know how to support it so it's
the Phi for yeah just that fine I just
to freeze it on c8 yeah yeah and maybe
we will have Queen b3 now because III
like everything everything black has
done sort of looks pretty but maybe here
with the pawn on f5 we cannot even go E
5 is 6 honestly yeah I I really don't
like giving up the d5 square for the
promises but you never but but it's very
it's going to be only 6 though which is
not nothing mm-hmm but also also rook f3
to h3 yeah I like that
Rilke for the h4 I like that yeah it
could be it could be that he Courage's
really should have spent a bit more time
there yeah I think when I saw him sort
of more or less instantly play route 81
and rock everyone I thought this is not
how you refute an i b8 it might be okay
but but you know when black is playing
so slowly it's maybe worth dedicating
some time on trying to just yeah I mean
4/5 though take it oh yeah just just
yeah and then and then I go for some
kind of position yeah I guess but this
is this is some something else like here
it feels like white as definite
potential 95 maybe yeah yeah no I'm not
disagreeing but it sounds maybe it's
interesting and maybe it's worth
considering for black but yeah this is a
this is a very messy position where I'm
not I'm not certain I'm winning the poll
on the 5 back because we're quite
happily playing g4 next move 6 followed
by Bishop d3 yeah i blundered that yeah
I will I will I will happily admit I
blunder that that's getting the Queen
trapped in the middle of the board nah I
like this i active idea very much Magnus
you're yeah let's go back to the game
and think that that's really nice but
the current position if you will please
Peter yeah
and and this is the explanation for the
move rocks III he car realized b5 is
probably coming so he has over protected
upon on b3 to be able to just drop back
to b2 and not allow the opening of the B
file with ba ba no because that would
that would actually be quite awkward
here for white I'm pretty sure and now
black needs to be quite quick exactly
the move B 65 was quite to middle it in
many ways kind of ruined blacks
structure doesn't he need a powerful
follow up like fi Peter I mean that's
what I'm looking at I just don't know
what it does necessarily like it's it's
a nice move on general grounds but I'm
not sure if ever before is even a threat
so now white can proceed with whatever
he was first of all and also there is
this right which maybe we need to be
slightly worried about gaining space
let's say Bishop goes back to c8 we go
ninety three and we claim that this this
pawn chain is now not that easy to
challenge right you got it you've got to
consider a b5 Fe as well that is true
you know maybe a fee but I think I and
then you'll have the the g4 square right
yeah that was the point no but even
there let's say even there yeah just
want one and it looks to me like we made
some progress with white at least the
bish point of to is now breathing and if
we get I don't know 93 and then three
trade the Queen comes in and it's a very
playable position and and dance played
an interesting which is Ruby I it's I
guess he still wants to go CP after yeah
that's the question my god is he
inviting a B and then saying haha fooled
you and taken with the pawn or is he
actually completely ruining a structure
with Ruby fine that looks night a for as
something comes right or yeah a night a
for even even 93 steel might be a
playable move as well I don't know I
just don't even like h2 h3 here and what
is black aiming towards and then
eventually I will start coming out of
the core and I don't know if I need h3
but
- I chime in if you will necklace it
seems to me like today's modern players
do not make moves like b6 b5 easily
committing themselves they're all about
keeping their options open and
prophylactically playing b6 bc5 to miami
thinking is a real committal move is it
the type of move that you might that you
would have done yourself as black well
not not when my opponent plays rook c3
specifically preparing for that move
then I would be very very wary of doing
that I feel like I don't know I I'm not
convinced about about the players timing
time expenditure and in this game it
feels like they're playing a bit too
fast to be honest because positionally
speaking there are there are many
decisions that they've made that haven't
been obvious at all and they haven't
spent so much time on it so he has taken
with the rook very interesting and yeah
I wanted to agree with that it's very
very unusual to see a complicated
position like this with many decisions
which needed attention and both of them
having like 10 and 9 minutes on the
clock right yeah like I can are you tell
you if I've been playing with either
color here I would be at five minutes
because I mean it the positions are so
rich and interesting so so many so many
pawn breaks and so much so much tension
that you know you want to make the right
decisions right you just you know it's
not really a position you can play
entirely on field okay Peter a B look B
five your knee-jerk assessment prefer D
prefer white you prefer black and if so
why well structurally white is doing I
mean clearly doing much better but his
pieces I still somewhat
somewhat bunched up and you need to
settle on a plan but I'm I think the the
last let's say three moves have made me
start liking white a lot more I don't
know if I believe white is already
better or or something like that but I
thought after okie g8 it was black who
was pushing for advantage and I'm much
much less sure about that now I think
probably black needs to worry about
equalizing if anything well Magnus a
moment ago he thought that the nighttime
p2 is maybe White's worst piece and he
started with the move Knight a four do
you agree with Magnus all right well I
would but he's almost he car has already
played ninety four and this is
particularly surprising because that
appears to allow for yeah I was I was
gonna say what do you do about it for
yeah ba ba 95 just wins in exchange does
it is Giovanni's hanging so your touch
doesn't work anymore because route 81 is
a check mmm so a 4895 8x b5 my take c3
is just flat-out winning for black if
you play something like Quincy to you
probably still lost right after okay so
he's gonna for ya and and he carro is
judging by what I'm seeing on my screen
not entirely happy and understandably so
because you should not have been
allowing I I think allowing a four is
just a mistake even if he ends up
somehow stabilizing here and not yeah
the move Knight to c4 is far from
obvious I mean both both d3 and a4 are
also decent squares for an item you
could very much argue that the move you
mentioned earlier on H h3 would be would
be more useful um I'm not sure I think
maybe he wanted to go 9 c4 just to put
it there and maybe play Queen a1 next or
something like that but yeah it's it's
very unclear to me why he even felt it
was the best square for the knight and
honestly also judging by the facial
reactions there he may have missed
something about a 4 and now I'm back to
liking black quite a bit because well
you you you are not
of guaranteed I think to keep everything
intact after rock dc1 I like though with
the intention of going a B rook takes b3
and but but this is still awkward
of course yeah but it I don't quite see
how it gets taken apart and maybe if you
if you give a larger yeah Ruby b8 I
guess and just continue putting pressure
because it's really not that easy to
make moves with y know but like I can go
like Ruby three beats ooh I like that
move rook the AEA but I really like
85-84 for black
I see the a pawn as being more of a
weakness and the B 3 pawn is actually a
great Han and to just allow the move a5
a4 to my mind I think that was just a
flat-out oversight does does look like
that I don't think I don't think if you
support a4 is possible I don't think you
ever allow it
yeah I agree with both of you the pawn
on B 3 is integral to everything white
wants to do positionally so removing
that base an excellent achievement for
for black and that black an item b4 is
well supported even without even without
the pond so this is definitely a good
trade for black and now there is no way
black is worse I would say you know I
suspect like black should be better it's
just not easy to exploit but if we if we
continue looking at that line for
instance and it's just it's just going
to be difficult for white to get out of
the corner maybe you can play Queen Avon
if you can play clean a1 maybe it's not
that bad because then I can put maybe
play rugby c3 in next move and start you
know carefully bringing the pieces back
towards decent squares but there's all
kinds of jumps here you need to evaluate
about rook d8 AAA we take on b3 rook
takes be 3 and we go rook a8 we just say
you mentioned theatre but the Queen's
kind of caught on the Queen side and
it's gonna have a very difficult time
just wow I don't know I think maybe I
like this
db8 actually stopping Queen Yvonne
because it feels like maybe the only
move I would play in the Blitz game here
with white Israel b3 b2 but then what am
I playing next move where are these
pieces going
rooks III Queen f1 yeah maybe you know
maybe we do get out somehow because
black does experience here a problem of
lacking an easy way to increase the
pressure I don't okay you can go 982 but
I think that's just nothing yeah we
probably just go back yeah think we go
back yeah Oh rugby - now Queen B - 994
we have to go route C 3 yeah it's uh
it's very touch-and-go but it does
appear to hold for white leg does have a
draw on the spot with my take to Roxy
tonight before here by the way more I'm
thinking about it any arguments to be
made for the immediate rook a8 that's
what he played actually very nicely
spotted by mine by yawns yeah well that
was a lucky guess actually like like
because you were mentioning Magnus rook
c1 to c3 Queen at one am i helping by
taking on b3 not sure and here at least
I was thinking if you do take on a4 and
what takes a fourth is a knight a to
issue that you might not be I mean it
might hurt your feelings move like
Knight a - yeah I thought Queen b3 but
the problem is night a 2 will still be a
huge threat after something like group a
4 a 8 and I might might just be remember
actually yeah here here is over I think
I don't think it's stoppable mmm I think
it just lands next move in wins material
so Yates
yikes indeed yeah ever question I'm
watching in Cairo on camera and it
scared him he's worried yeah it's very
obvious from his facial expressions and
Magnus do you actually watch the other
guys
camera when you play in such an event oh
yeah most of the time I I do especially
if if I have a good position I wanna I
wanna see them squirm I think I think
you can be a little bit more open right
on camera it's what would the board it's
a little bit more professional and so on
I think in those online events there
there's much more happening yeah with
the facial expressions
yeah because because you're at home and
even though you know your opponent can
can see you and on camera you're gonna
be more open with your emotions and I
think that's one of the good things
about about this format it's really
there are so many funny clips are from
those tournaments and it's really in
tradition the Magnus who was your worst
over the board opponent doing it
somebody like screwing in the pieces or
copying over the board or banging the
clock anybody stand out that was
unpleasant for you no I know I never
played Gary so I played him alive I mean
I could feel that the whole the whole
setup was just from from years and
torture playing Gary for for you so of
course of course how do you say I'm
lying you have no such concerns of
course
so no nobody's making you unhappy no
it's it's all good to be a fair yeah I
think I think okay so he Carl has played
something very forcing I'm sorry to drag
the discussion away room he played takes
takes and then Ruby three something that
reading is very precise calculation
because it might just lose but so far so
far I don't see I was very interested in
95 oh he's played night ace yeah night I
too is much strong now okay III didn't
see that he'd played it no you said it
you said it a split second before I saw
the past okay so he's just sacked hang
on
yeah and Ruby on this is just this is
just a fool
Oh fool exchanged up yeah no wait wait a
sec wait a sec 93 93 well that's all
were already all on the board and I was
just no okay I was thinking okay 85 but
okay it might be one to five with the
intention of Bishop c5 but you probably
lose too many pieces in the process yeah
90 do you actually I didn't I did know
that is this better of worse than what
he got
he'll be a pawn down in a minor key
sending right yeah but that probably is
more loss than the position he got is it
I don't know I'm not sure like Italy but
the position he has is really awful yeah
that that one you don't expect to hold
because eventually something happens in
the center and the position gets opened
and your setup collapses the fact that
black has the blue bishops here is very
relevant I think absolutely bishop
actually he doesn't even have a pawn for
it's just a row no it's just it's just a
row can i you really need to need to get
the Knights away from from c3 sorry c4
mm-hmm you need why I'm very benign f1
I'm very attached to the idea of claim
Bishop before here just to make sure
they stay there yeah but he played
Quincy 8 which is also something I was
looking at because you cannot take
Bishop d7 96 Queen d7 collects but he
allowed it seriously though I think
maybe this mate might be a good chance
just go Knight b6 take on d7 take enough
faith and then yeah he's done it I think
this is not about chance to minor pieces
and pawn I will say i blundered the
existence of knight of one but I don't
believe this holds OG for now I don't
think this holds Magnus what's happened
to you you're making a suggestion that Y
can construct the fortress yeah this is
this is actually quite striking yeah
let's say we go King G do we go no jeez
three and then G 4 is very important
here because G 6 a 5 was one of the
reasons I didn't believe it would hold
eventually but if it's not if we stopped
it all together I think back has to go
for G 6 H 5 and then well I don't know
because I mean King G let's imagine
black Cohoes HC right and white gets the
pawn to h5 I mean this is not even in
particular in particular maybe even this
set up to make sure that this is no
discussion like this is a dead draw Wow
yeah I think I think I will agree with
that yes well III don't even yeah I'm
not sure even sure I want to play d5
just not to give like the e5 square for
for the King I just want to go 93 King G
2 and wait forever
so he's country 6 which is obviously
more sensible but yeah I think that
setup is is very wrong but now we go
King G - I guess H 5 H 3 maybe or
there's also there's also this option
yes as you said I mean bishop and before
was just way better at least practically
speaking oh I love that move I love
keeping the Knights together
forcing the knights together yeah that's
why I didn't I wasn't crazy about the
route k-6 move to begin with because of
Bishop before there was a 65 thread so I
think unfor gotta go root K 1 that's the
thing really one Bishop before rook c1
and we start running towards this should
be decent chances to hold I mean we have
7 but then you're sort of tying up your
own pieces right mhm and you got rook
see - now you see - in 93 yeah this is
this is a setup you want to you want to
have everybody towards the King side and
not only unsupported squares yeah but I
think maybe just really discounted rook
takes c6 as a move he was
I'm pretty sure he will get the same
position but hang on a second
wasn't it I think mean see one check may
have been a mistake
think we'd take here and we go Quincy
three and we try to stop chief over
everything right yeah yeah Quincy one
was probably when she won is a bad
mistake I feel because you just give
white like 210 big night if one is going
to happen anyway why are we driving in
there
can you stop light from playing g4
though do you for Queen C 3 I think wins
a pawn here so yeah no that's clear with
Knight f1 yeah Quincy 3 yeah just just
play Quincy 3 anyway and at least make
it difficult for you
if this make it difficult for your
opponent to achieve the setup he so
badly wants Bishop III Queen d3 King
yeah I can even maybe start with a five
already
yeah a 5 EF 23 and so on this prob'ly
ends up falling apart but the one they
got I'm I'm less sure he's gone for f5
not h5 by the way oh this is interesting
okay okay so he clearly wants take
everything Queen g5 and then and an h4
h5 this looks like trouble for I'm
wondering about this like do we do we
have actually shake any of this off
I put the pawn on f6 and then I never
Queen up for Quinn it for H and H for H
for H 3 you do yeah
H for H 3 is very high you just but I I
mean Bishop g3 is much better try though
than f6
this is still I would say not obvious
yeah but we probably leaning towards
this being winning right it's somehow
maybe queen g6 is a good move yeah Oh
still king king h2 if Queen f7 there's a
check on d6 yeah and then back to G 2 I
suppose I mean
I agree with the the leaning towards
winning thing but it's far from obvious
no no yeah there's there's a lot of play
left here for sure and hey Cara still
has three minutes to consider here which
i think is very valuable because you
need to settle on a set up here somehow
you need to figure out which one you
want there's also this option but
probably not great right I remember very
nice actually gone for this his he's
opted for this I remember a very
difficult ending that was won by a young
Tim on of Queen versus two bishops he
beat the two bishops but it actually
required some real precision if bishop
in not bishop at night versus queen is
that easy well it's it should be easier
but but easy very much depending on
where the pawns are cool who was that
Pulaski game against that was I think
Pulaski Ganner yeah I wanted to say
Geller but I wasn't a hundred percent
yeah I think I'm pretty sure it together
yeah that's the that's the famous one
the one that you know books are written
about but but that's against against two
bishops so I guess Fe he goes FV right
pretty sure he goes every yeah the here
many squares right yeah I think it kind
of it gets in and then you start running
out of running out of things to do I
mean yeah came to d3 Quinta for then age
five yeah something like that probably
should win eventually here I would
really be scared that the night on g3 is
going to be driven away you're gonna go
Queen up for Queen g4 h 5 h 4 mm-hmm
Bad's gonna happen this doesn't even
look close maybe maybe we take with the
night actually and we play something
like a CH 3 and we we try to keep this
formation this looks like a better
attempted fortress
I actually thought taking everything on
f5 might have been the best chance but
okay I think I prefer
Knight takes e4 to f3 take c4 I don't
think those two pawns are gonna stay
abreast for a long time your head yes
what do you think I mean practically
speaking also sorry this is f4 is
therefore completely unreasonable why
would you do that Peter Knight just to
separate the knight from from the bishop
and now let's say I play King - - and
then Queen e2 and and then I claim that
my king can just start running towards I
don't know g3 and white will never
reconnect his life pieces I was kind of
looking at that and I don't particularly
like it but I was wondering if it's as
stupid as all that but it is a bit an
unnatural I think in this way and every
490 [ __ ] of 7 on the board
okay so 94 was actually acara I was
actually fishing there for you Magnus
for a moment would you have recaptured
with the pawn or the night well yeah I
think in this case I very much agree
that night gives more chances h7h mm-hmm
yeah and now that the King starts its
march towards towards the the center in
the Kings side and I think eventually we
will start seeing some kinds of super
swans where Cara will find it difficult
to make a move I think you wanna you
wanna force h5 at some point then maybe
bring the King all the way back because
there is no there are no entry squares
they're not not yet here not yet so
imagine if you will break it down first
Peter either black King is gonna come to
t3 yay
the White Knight is gonna be saved
sitting on e4 or g3 just oscillating
back and forth
hmm how do you break it down how do you
big question is can be even force h5 can
wipe just play 94 here
that was my quest I was thinking like
going going like c6 in such a position
but Bishop g3 is a move Jonas
because otherwise h5 is the only only
move that doesn't loose on the spawn hmm
which I'm trying to resist play right
yeah you wanna resist playing because
basically why that's a fortress at the
moment without the pawn moving to h5 is
a fortress right exactly which also
raises the question whether black should
go edge fire actually breaking news okay
he's just gone h5 the one move I thought
we were trying to avoid so he is now
going to be playing Bishop to Bishop g1
forever and hoping this this said I'm
cold now now the King has got to go to
g5 as bike that's the only so cringy
five and now we reroute the king towards
the g5 square eventually yeah and and
then we set up some something yeah the
way Queen I mean King d3 just gives
absolutely nothing usually so well yeah
I can even do that I guess I don't know
my life yeah let's let's see we got here
and why did not have Bishop e3 check for
some reason how do we in this position
king h4 I get Queen e2 in Nanking edge
for yeah yeah it looks pretty clean so
let's say King here already it's
difficult to make a move you go here
here here and then black play something
like Queen c2 and you are either
allowing quick King h3 which wins or
you're dropping the h5 phone and then
obviously everything will start falling
off yeah this does feel like it should
be it should be clean enough is there a
way not to allow King g5 let's say I go
94 here and I start playing Bishop g1
which 15
oh that is dirty now there there has to
be a way to get it to g5 right there is
no way this can work like I play queen
bee 593 King f6 and and he's also just
allowed it so I think maybe he karo
didn't believe it was possible but I
think this probably ends up being being
unstoppable oh really what's what's his
idea here
King f5 I don't I don't get it I don't
know I think I think maybe he thinks
this is holding but I don't think it is
I think once the King lense on h4 the
game kind of effectively ends something
about Knight f1 I find two compliant
yeah that was that was a strange
decision yeah was also h5 like I get I
get that you want to simplify your
decisions later on but yeah I'm not sure
what's going on because he is now just
giving up the pollen h5 for with like no
fight and that's never going to hold
like we know that's never going to hold
no that is that is strange very strange
expected yeah maybe he just didn't
believe it was holding in general but
still it feels like from move 48 to move
54 we just went from a position where
there was a discussion to be had to a
position where there's really not much
to talk about anymore Magnus for as we
started today's broadcast
we had a remark on the amazing comeback
of Hikaru yesterday he won with black on
demand he won with white on demand
that's pretty impressive yeah that's
that's it was an awesome comeback and he
will have to do something along the same
lines I'm really gonna be interested to
see what kind of opening he chooses with
Wyatt in in the 4th game if he gets to
that because he hasn't really got much
at all in in these in this Berlin Bishop
c6 lines and he's been is this a chance
at all mostly cuz of where the pieces
are I guess not yeah there's no way this
can hold this can work right th okay
yeah it's an interesting trying I think
it's the only try but I like the bra is
white is not actually threatening to
take on h6 so there has to be a way to
like
make a clever pass here which suddenly
threatens King g6
I don't know queen gy really Oh Queen
Nia Quincy 3 or some some of like that
and maybe I booking of two and I want to
take with the night now but I probably
will just the king h4 and then Queen c2
check and the King comes in yeah that
that's never going to hold
that's never going to hold so king five
yeah I don't know I want to get you in
on the discussion a little bit how is
our social media all doing are they
enjoying our broadcasts and enjoying
Magnus on stream absolutely thrilled to
have Magnus on the broadcast and
everybody is just happy to have your
insights Magnus they have tons of
questions for you I I don't think I can
ask all of them but a couple of the
questions included your laptop and mouse
a lot of people are wondering for these
online events did you choose a different
Mouse to play we do you have any tips on
what laptop or computer to use can you
tell us about your equipment for these
online events I'm not an expert of the
type of the arena that you played and
you weren't very happy with your mouse I
think it's you generally use a different
mouse mouse speed for for for rapid and
blitz bullets but I think for for this
format frankly like anything and
anything goes since speed is not really
a factor unless you get to the
Armageddon then you should probably
change your settings and he's gone
exactly for Queen C 3 yeah that's a
seemingly a nice clean move and knocking
of - yeah King and I serve a king of
took English for and and some kind of a
swift conclusion to all this because
yeah
there's just no stopping this a matter
we'll see are you in the Microsoft
family of computers are you an apple
computer user well I've always been
always just thought that chess base runs
a lot better on and basically all kinds
of chess software's runs better on PC
and buy a lot better you mean it runs
you can you can run programs that allow
you to yeah but like once we get into
the emulators you know it's yeah we so
I'm trying to be more diplomatic than
was needed sure
basically then now after this move Queen
takes d4 white black just has a past
moment I think this is simply easy
suddenly yes three is also falling yeah
the game is the game is effectively over
and will be over in a moment because the
f3 pawn is not going to survive the next
couple of months exactly the car I'm
shaking I mean you play dakara so many
times over the board the head shaking
ever affects you did it ever did you
ever wrongly get get the wrong signal
from the car ah no it doesn't really
affect me much did you like it when he
score me okay let me can we just go back
so the game is over Queen of three hmm
that's that's done let's just go back
for one moment I wanted to see the
moment when he played a five takes takes
and and after in 93 h5 oh yeah yeah he
takes Queen D 593 h5 to play a four here
ah okay so we need to have a talk about
this right
presumably the ideas night h5 yeah yeah
night is five I can include Queenie for
Chet but you actually aren't dropping it
yeah I'm not losing the nights you know
and and now eventually I was sort of
assumed lady yeah but maybe this is very
important actually that I get to f3 yeah
and then you like you have to assume
that eventually the squares run out
right the King just starts running
towards h3 and the squares should run
out yeah this is probably Justin
straight for everyone wow I was about to
suggest h2 h3 no I think at some point
it will be it will become a super song
of some sort and yeah you you you end up
losing here I'm not so sure guys don't
play h3 I apologize put the knight on f1
the bishop on g3 in the bishop on e5
aren't I happy never you know my list
upon Quincy for yeah that but also let's
say let's say I even I allow them yeah
and then and then I start kind of
inexorably march towards it there are
three minutes worse yeah yeah you know I
don't think this year there don't thing
this cold also the bishop is not solid
on e5 at all c5 well very nice when Ford
Engler and set the table again we're in
the third day of this quarterfinal game
Lehren news just scored a victory giving
a moat one and a half 1/2 point lead he
needs two and a half points to secure
his passage to the semi-finals and a
date with Magnus Carlsen should
shouldn't use the word appointment an
appointment with Magnus Carlsen
that's the winners of prize a whirling
lunch a large team lunch from he car is
one of you he's got to make a come
back you have two games to do it should
ding we're in win this game that would
be a short day for us that would be but
I think yet sir we are here for the long
broadcast and more action obviously all
the viewers on Twitch on YouTube and
just 24 everything for an exciting day
and lots of action and that that could
mean if he Karl makes a comeback he has
two more games to tie the score to then
lead to two blitz games I think that's
what most of the people are wishing for
just more checks action on the board in
general thanks to everybody tuning in by
the way thousands of people watching on
YouTube over 10,000 watching on twitch
thanks for being here and obviously
thanks to the world champion Magnus
Carlsen for joining us I think if Magnus
you would like to stay for the rest of
the games we are very happy to have you
and Christopher thank you for being here
as well - Magnus has flown away but he
promised he will return as the quote
goes the crystal is still with us yeah I
have a question do we make a bet there
that the Dutch defense will appear again
on the board I think it's increasingly
likely yeah I'm pretty sure
[Music]
g4 is not met by night of 6 if d4
happens Jing has played 94 openings but
if he does go one before which i think
is very likely I think Hikaru continues
with the Dutch because he got playable
positions I think every single time he
tried this in this tournament he hasn't
always won them but he got playable
fighting positions I think pretty much
every single time yeah I was when I was
dressing for this broadcast I was
thinking to wear bright orange yeah for
for yesterday Gary's birthday and Hikaru
winning with the Dutch defense so it
felt very appropriate but it was too
bright felt it was too irritating but
camera but House of Orange would
appreciate that Chris Powell I just
wanted to say thank you again for
joining as one d4 keep it simple a 40%
discount thank you so much for joining
us Christophe it's
Rizzoli's have you thanks a lot guys
absolutely and we're just gonna take a
very short commercial break we'll see
you on the other side hello this is
crystals alaikum and welcome to my keep
it simple one default course
[Music]
hello this is Chris of delegate and
welcome to my keep it simple one for
course
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Cara Juana
Alexander Chris Chuck and bent Allah
Hari Krishna go premium at chess 24 to
challenge them and gain full access to
the world's most entertaining chess
platform
there are more moves in chess than atoms
in the universe
only one moves hence again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is John Bartholomew and this is
the checkmate patterns manual hello
everyone and welcome back to our live
coverage with adjustable masters we just
saw an incredibly complex and very
intriguing game and Magnus you just
mentioned that during the break you
checked with the engine about the move
f-for what
what was your discovery no there were I
thought there were there were some
interesting things first of all after
rook c1 computer just seems to think
black is better and that surprisingly we
actually got a lot of these positional
things right that the whole that black
was better here after 96 not before and
that he miss plated a bit later but that
night BC 4 was a serious mistake that
gave like the initiative again what I
found interesting though is that we were
discussing f4 here and black should go
Knight a 6 and so on f5 there are some
interesting lines like c5 d5 knife
before Queen b3 or or that there was
maybe King edge say at first actually
and then there were some c6 ideas for
from black there as well but it was just
complicated but probably better for
whites what was interesting is that we
we thought f5 was probably a decent
response here and the computer just says
95 white is completely winning at least
at low depth which I thought was pretty
fascinating
Wow just the king side just gets
completely destroyed yeah yeah
FV 4 F 4 F 5 i5 is even stronger yeah f5
and I mean when you look at it it sort
of makes sense but yeah yeah this is
this is not even interesting this is
just winning for white Wow
sorry but we are in Game three let's
and it looks like it's means Indy and
Peter take it away well I would like to
pass it on to somebody anybody
aye aye aye aye I have zero games on
castles 96 in my entire life I used to
play 9b d7 but nobody who has any any
sense does that so the bionet have you
played the by night with any caller
Magnus yeah a little little bit I don't
have much success against it as as black
to be fair I tried a five once against
Kramnik and I was just lost and
miraculously saved the game then I had a
few games with white with with more with
more success obviously ninety-eight is
it's a specialty of the car I think he's
beaten vitiated with this maybe wish
this game was was 992 that could be
actually hmm but basically the themes
are the same you just go 98 you you
expand that the kingside you don't care
about the queenside at all and you try
to deliver mates
yeah but specifically guess the bayonet
I'm not sure I've seen this very much
because you are considering so much
ground on the queenside that it feels
like you're you're just never going to
be fast enough but no but I've
definitely seen a curved blade play it
against the by on it as well yeah that's
why I was asking for help because I
really don't know anything about this
yeah I see I think he's even gonna like
aged 6 maybe before playing f51 you were
right about the game against issue
that's almost 10 years ago in in London
London yeah the famous Kenan yeah um I
feel like he's won some he beat Gelfand
once I think world team's 2010 he also
had a spectacular win as black against
Wesley so
oh yeah but that that would that was a
different mind altogether yeah that was
91 yeah so a couple of games against
Veselin in 2017 a game against chicken
in 2009 in that game against Vichy and
also one game against gotta and I would
like so far I see five on my screen I
would like four more for our esteemed
panel to guess how many points he car
scored out of those five
I'm gonna guess four four and a half
four and a half okay
yeah I'm gonna go for four and a half
what was the waiting
yeah it's sorry for my lag sorry it's
it's actually quite stunning to me
because I think by right soo this should
be quite a good quite a good Kings
Indian for white but he car just
understands the Kings it's it's such a I
think of regrettable thing for the the
chess world in general that he switched
to the Queens gambit declined apart from
his opponents who are probably enjoying
the switch but by the way help me out
here or for all of those people in our
audience who are playing the Kings
Indian defense and enjoy positions like
this in their league games and their
clout games why is this a good Kings
Indian defense for white isn't black
you you pushed your B pawn in your Avon
congratulations this isn't black got the
so to speak ideal Kings Indian attack
going here guys what what's what's wrong
with blacks position here well I think
once again my understanding is I wanted
to say rudimentary it's not even that
it's really meant or I think it's just
wrong which is a which is a bigger
problem then then it being the villain
being professionals we can help I think
white made kind of good strides on the
Queen side and he also maintains this
idea of going 95 96 which is something
if you compare this let's say with the
normal ninety to ninety eight lines
which use
like existed for the Eternity and and
then there's the the race going on all
91 97 perhaps which are kind of closer
closer in spirit 93 at five of three or
four and so on here the light has
already migrated away from a three and
you know the battlegrounds are a lot
more defined black has this you know
typical player McQueen side where is
white
we'll start something on the car on the
other side of the board whereas in the
position we have here I think white is
he's gotten somewhere on the queenside
he hasn't actually considered the
kingside yet let me by and just say okay
I'm playing Knight takes e4 Peter you
will take Schneider falling and I like I
seen a game of Bobby Fischer from the 60
memorable games waiting at night at 594
and this is supposed to be just bad
right because white goes like this
before okay three Bishop b2 eventually
takes out this Knight and the bishop on
g7 never really becomes a real boy this
I like quite strongly would suggest for
black not to do I think this is just
yeah I think this is not good I would
like for my for my for Magnus to chime
in here because I might be wrong but I
was just going to say that you asked me
about my experience in in these kinds of
position and I suddenly remembered I
think it was before the match against
match against Kramnik I mean I'm not
sure if I'm revealing too much here but
I I think at this point this is part of
chess history so Vichy was perfect
preparing d4 and I was basically there
as just to play training games which was
extremely unpleasant in a sense because
I was told just to try everything
against d4 and he had he had prep
everywhere obviously and so one of the
things was I was
to play play the Kings Indian and just
tried to just try to make him so I do
have some experience there and I as far
as I can remember like the first two or
three games against me she I just made
to him on the Kings side and then after
that I I lost every every game basically
and I saw my appetite for for these
particular positions waned a bit I find
it interesting though the approach that
ding has gone for here with with rookie
one and yeah that that wasn't very
obvious and actually I'm quite surprised
by okay - I was pretty sure okay three
was coming aren't you always pushing it
on a three in this position yeah it just
looks better protects III the third bank
is very much relevant mm-hmm I was I was
just expecting the rook to lend on a
three and uh and then he chose this
square which is I guess you have to
right mm-hmm
yeah he's he's paying attention to the
f2 square but I don't know how black
would even mount any kind of an offense
against they have to pawn nice so in
those training games you played where
they blitz what was the time control
that you were playing the Train ah yeah
generally generally blitz okay okay so
take it away g6 g5 gentleman Bishop d3 I
assume but I guess black just goes Queen
g7 and then 96 this is a very playable
position yeah this this is looking a
little bit like those real opposites
that aren't played a bit exactly and
like you soup of you used to used to
used to play this is like I can I can
remember a few games like you change
these bishops but you have so many you
have so much space on the Kings side
that you feel like you're sort of you're
sort of okay I would be tempted to go
age 4 here as White's like I did
something similar again seeker and in
the previous previous tournament
and no no I mean without without Bishop
III I just straightaway yeah maybe yeah
that that makes a lot more sense I'm not
not sure it's great though also yeah g4
was not forced efore was also an option
yeah e4 yeah I can't count doesn't work
right HJ no it doesn't work my default
where gh and who knows yeah who knows
it's the kind of position you you want
in a semi must-win game so yeah I think
I think luck is extremely happy for that
specific reason yeah you don't actually
care about the the quote-unquote
evaluation of this and once again I'd
like to have the rookin a3 here yeah I
was gone I was gonna say the same thing
a line like Knight X takes mister chief
oh yeah thankfully exactly yeah like you
you really want the knight on c3 here to
not be hanging
it's Mike's really good for right by the
way Nigel g4 age 5 green G 6 inches 6
and we're keeping the pin on yeah yeah
but with Rokon a3 this would have been
just like if you imagine this position
with the rock on a3 blood probably is
just helpless everything L up says by
the way Magnus I don't know if you've
seen this yourself but seeing a lot of
games especially I guess from the
Italian where black place h6 g5 and the
move like what you've played h2h or just
somehow blacks not getting disturbed
after advancing his pawn shield he's
doing pretty okay yeah and I guess in in
these particular situations where that
we have in the game right where white is
not really going for for the whole
keeping the pawn need for F 3 and then
c5 then the the space that you've gained
the
queenside isn't that useful so in that
sense I would say black is doing fairly
okay here h3 that looks timid to me I
don't quite know what yeah I guess isn't
intending some kind of night it's true
at some point taking some control over
light squares but your car is happy here
there is no doubt about that
yeah plant the night on f4 Peter yeah
this is what this is what I've been I've
been looking at 96 94 where heroes are
anytime anytime Peters on the attack
everybody you'll see his arrows
improving well at night on f4 Peter I'm
not sure we need to do it immediately
I'm also I'm also looking at the move
like 27 keeping things slightly more
flexible but yeah I guess we can do it
because I was worried about Bishop d3
but I guess we can play Queen d7 here
the issue is once again in a must-win
game how happy are we about the fact
that white can actually get the Queen's
off here I would say not very happy at
all I would say that this is a position
advantage white yeah and in this
particular endgame I think we are quite
happy we played h3 because some kind of
an expansion with g4 and h5 would be
quite useful to black but it's
unavailable yeah this is just good for
white I think I mean the only the only
chance you could see for her bark is
some quick c6 but I don't believe it
yeah he's like Queeny Queeny 8 so he
wants the Queen on f7 or g6 maybe this
looks weird
yeah just extend of gets in the way of
his own play I think a little bit you're
still let's say you imagine I don't know
which passing move to make for wide but
after Queen g6 you're still not
threatening g4 because Knight h4 is very
painful so it's by the way do we never
play g5 g for in these types of
positions or is there a kind of a set of
circumstances where it might be useful
well not after Knight h2 I mean we can
probably withdraw withdraw we serve by
the way I think we have a tree dedicated
to you from mr. dodge is saying bizarre
move by hikari when he Kerwin Bishop f5
clearly the move a six which would
achieve the symmetrical bathtub was the
way to go I think of yours are still
waiting for a six and your thoughts on
the symmetrical bathtub very much of you
know now we are happy now we are
ecstatic indeed yeah I've raised some
some questions honestly like he Karan
doji are an unlikely dream dream team
but if that ever happens you know that
collab would be you know one for the
ages serious romance which raises the
question wasn't a five a six something
that white could have aspired to and
then must have explained they six that's
the only explanation I have because I
don't think in this position black has
you know time to spare so if he chose to
spend the tempo and she was probably
worried about a 6 B 6 95 in some
positions a future day
yeah like might be fine might have just
put the full clamp on the queenside 9 h2
and well he's he's cut he's taken the g4
square under control necklace do you
like this I think Bing has made
considerable progress here mm-hmm
yeah the bishop will go to g4 probably
our just III also yeah although you also
that yeah Bishop takes you both both
options seem fine but I I guess T 3 is
just simpler play Bishop d3 you trade
those off playing the knight on e4 and
start pushing for c5 like the the old
fashioned way of playing these positions
and I have to say now the route looks
actually looks pretty good and I - who
it goes to ship do later potentially and
supports the c5 plane which begs the
question gentlemen why aren't we afraid
is black of allowing Bishop g4 the
Bishop e6 isn't the bishop like nice but
you go at night at 5:00 just stopping it
okay yeah that's why I sort of feel like
Bishop d3 is it's a bit more to the
point and time well by the way if you
really want to make a draw here with
wides
I can imagine something like Bishop g4 9
f5 just chop it off and then you go 94
or even g4 you just set up with g4 94 f3
and then and then what yeah but I I
don't think it's called for I think
there's no absolutely not absolutely not
you know cuz I think being at this point
probably feels like he is reasonably
safe and has a a not insignificant
chance of just not having to play the
next blank game yeah absolutely and
again for our viewers Hikaru Nakamura
trails this match 1 and a half to 1/2 if
the England should win he's in the
semi-finals and that was very important
Magnus because as we came on show we
were explaining on and did a great job
of explaining why this particular
matchup is really crucial for the finals
that if he Carlo were to win this match
he would go on to play in the legends
and likely absolutely secure a spot
should somebody like yourself win two of
the events well that's his problem not
mine good boy but you set it up the
whole magnus carlsen tour was being set
up
you wanted to reward people who played
in the tournaments and that deep into
the new quarters or the semies or the
finals
yes originals gonna have three um do you
like that I wasn't going to touch that
pawn to be honest type no but I don't
particularly mind yeah I was I was
wondering about even maybe the immediate
c5 because I want my rook on c2 and the
immediate c5 Queen f7 you know things
can can get out of hand
yeah possibly be five is a midweek f3
Queen f7 play dia the issue for black
here is that h5 is extremely difficult /
impossible to achieve because of how
weak the pawn on d5 is if you go 94 you
instantly allow Bishop e3 and but I
should that's that's one of my points
now with the pollen f3 I am I am much
less sure about let's say let's just get
this structure on the board I'm much
less happy about this with white because
[ __ ] p5 Queen a4 becomes you know a
part of this like we can probably
control it but it wasn't there at all if
the pawn was enough to know I think I'll
suffer for for black here you gotta get
give serious considerations to rock the
eight and then c6 I mean most okay so
it's gone worked yet mmm-hmm
I mean most probably you're just weak in
your position but you got to do
something and there's not a lot of there
aren't there aren't a lot of active
plants you can plant your knight on d4
whenever you want but then where it goes
Bishop e3 and let are never ever
advancing so the only active place is c6
yeah I think I agree with that do we try
to stop it or so clearly ding with with
rook f2 he believes that this should not
be stopped so let's imagine they should
be to c6 we traig once on c6 Queen d2 is
black really gonna go d5
well maybe not straightaway but you can
start dreaming about it you you can
start maybe preparing for it and ding is
gonna be
b1 which is also a nod in that direction
but probably more of a nod in the
direction of c6 and I say nothing and I
invite you to take on d5 and then maybe
I take the Queen's off the board perhaps
yeah but you go 94 then defy is attacked
yeah I'm not sure I think he's he's lost
the thread a little bit I think well
there must have been a way to play more
more precisely from here yeah
because I mean objectively objectively
black just waits here I don't think it's
too easy to do much with with whites I
mean you got a you got a nice position
but whenever you start doing something
active then likes probably not gonna be
too unhappy about it so yeah it's a
different equilibrium to to maintain
here we've just seen the moved g8 h8
good waiting move theater yeah I mean if
we are planning to break something open
in the center I guess removing any kind
of tactical questions about the the
Queen and the king on the same diagonal
is not bad even though it looks
extremely remote and not that relevant
yeah I guess after c6 it could become
come relevant but it's always a
difficult choice here to choose a square
right because it could be useful to in
some lines exactly it's come Bishop b2
now that either a bishop takes g6 or
Bishop takes G 7 would be a check and
like as you said is it's extremely
remote but it might be relevant so you
don't love you really don't love any of
these squares for for the black King you
have to do something ok more directly
Hikaru trailing in the match what can he
do to disturb ding there in Peter I
think in particular his last few moves
are
very much an indication that he feels he
should postpone opening the position
until there's less time on the clocks
I'm once again it's maybe an
oversimplification but I do feel that
his play here is very indicative for
somebody who doesn't really want giving
anything concrete to calculate when
there is still seven minutes on the
clock which is a good I think good
practical choice I like by night I don't
you ideas of maybe Bishop f5 and Bishop
page three or potentially Bishop f5 and
routing the Knight to f4 I think that's
this fun Bishop h3 is unrealistic but he
just wants to get denied to to f4 and
then you know queen g6 maybe edge 4G 4G
4G for sorry yeah before exciting
interesting that ding is the first one
to to break the the deadlock here but b5
I guess he doesn't really feel like
waiting for another five moves I was
looking at 93 there I was something I
was kind of curious about I was just
trying to trade some pieces but I guess
Queen a4 is a little bit awkward did you
say breaking the bathtub deadlock
something along the other the bathtub in
severe danger now it might it might
completely disintegrate you gotta
consider a be here CP 10 Knight goes to
f5 and start start
or maybe Roque a first at some point
okay I guess he wants to go BC three
right and then I guess that's more
useful for white than for black sure
yeah I'm not sure yeah like we we now
have given white some you know clear
plans to although I mean I have to pay
attention to never that's the exactly
the point like 94 might just went upon
you know III managed to place my pieces
on such square I mean there's Queen see
their queen there's Queen b3 but you in
b3 yeah but I don't like I don't like
any of that yeah
what's the threat from what is he
intending to go b6 or ba ba and
something like what why has he played
before I think I think b6 must be it's
the idea absolutely I think b6 is
potentially huge I mean I could see
black center with b6 and Bishop 83 kind
of collapsing unless some action on the
queenside King side pardon me by black
stops white from just realizing a
breakthrough mm-hmm and yeah he carves
somehow completely ignored it which I
really don't think I like he played by
5b 696 and now yes the life is well g3
maybe it's just great maybe it's a very
clever move yeah that's more of a
confident man yeah yeah you really have
to believe in your your ideas here mr.
price three maybe even the immediate
Knight takes d5 might be dissin yeah or
okay - first I don't know which one is
stronger that is also very very good
option so he's saying h3 is not hanging
he's also saying you have just spent
three time be preparing him whenever
which leads absolutely nowhere and now I
will start playing on the queenside yeah
I really think you had to go a B and
then not in five to have any chance and
by the way this we're gonna have to is
certainly marvelous defenders that
turned out to be a stroke of genius it
just feels like ding glare in has played
this opening as a man just knows what
he's doing this is all looking great I
think this is just a very poor position
for black now it just sounds like Kings
you do I don't know if we need to even
or Bishop let's say we can we can go
directly [ __ ] play 398 Queen b3 or
something like this and mm and then it
eventually we will place you Fife and
everything will start crumbling why the
sort of better everywhere here III
really I mean I'm just repeating myself
here but I really hate I hated Bishop f5
there yeah that seemed that's him
strange allowing do you just good or bad
use had to take on b5 weakened d5 and
try to get countably this
absolutely no can be three played and
white-white has realized all of his
plans and black really just doesn't have
anything to show by the way we even with
an I don't see it the funny thing is it
can we take I guess we just played maybe
maybe we just play chief or here and
I've collected collected quietly yeah
yeah there's a g4 and Magnus you would
mention some ideas like this even
earlier it was cheap ride this painting
is well Peter there so oops
yeah and and maybe we are also
threatening g3 g4 right now for exactly
I was indeed exactly and then lick
really has nothing to show for anything
like his position is that's the kind of
position I used to get in King's Indian
which is why I abandoned the opening how
do you get these kind of positions Mia
Knight bd7 you not not these I think I
got something close to this against
Lukey once in a in a Monaco tournament
and that probably was the final nail in
the coffin because we all love Lukey but
when Lukey starts giving you positional
lessons like this you feel like maybe
the opening has something to do with it
yeah then well then you then you trick
him that's the no I lost the game
horribly no no okay sure I was expecting
a different different ending to that
story no no no none of my pieces ever
recovered and I I just lost the game
like for him I think it was very much
like a simultaneous Evon games like this
I'm oh it was such a promising story
sorry you had to suffer through that
that's brutal man Bishop h7 played which
is I think we can describe it as a move
yeah if you were to compare this exact
position to say the position ten moves
ago you would say that black is gone
backwards everywhere you know go
backwards and white has a pawn on d6 as
a knight on C
yes it's just it's it's all gone
horribly wrong
yeah this is this is not hard and again
just to boldly mention the army sure
being with Bing Lehren win this game you
know I'm appointment with Magnus Carlsen
in the semi-finals
yeah Luke Devon is a very logical move
here just reinforcing the opponent on d5
and preparing c5 and Hikaru goes bishop
g8 which I suspected was the idea of
which page 7 but it really doesn't make
it any better it's it's a very very
unpleasant position to to look at King
jus-just just enjoy it like you I can't
you to look at one age 4 is awesome
Thank You Magnus exactly James Ichiro
h1h born who's attacking whom on the
Kings side that looks yeah and and the
amazing part about this position is also
that there's this not the pollen b6 and
black can not attack it with any other
pieces so white is not even ripped e7
Queen e7 rook da and then I go Bishop c1
Bishop e3 and I say you force me to do
something I kind of wanted to do anyway
then you double the rook Sonia file and
you have one one threat yeah no it's a
little chest sadist it's just so bad I
think every good chess player is a bit
of a sadist exactly exactly and also I
wanted to point out that this might be
winning by fours question mark probably
not yeah probably we don't need to a lot
of text e5 and start calculating I still
feel like it might be very good but
there's a nice line here
sounds like [ __ ] paid to here and I
don't know what line tell me ok ok that
was nonsense that was that I mean I knew
that it wouldn't work but it doesn't
work for a number of reasons I was
thinking take everything on d5 take b7
and then take f8 and wish b4
there are many reasons it doesn't yeah
but mainly because there's nine takes be
six in the end oh no not that one not
that one Knight b6 and Bishop c5
yeah that's racially not losing then I
thought and here he has played King g2
and Hikaru goes back to h7 which means
that now we can play c5 without even
sacrificing any I think like that that's
Mike's only hope
really you take on me for you take on c5
oh you take only for first and many
pecans and any go 96 and you claim this
is the best position you've had in the
game or something yeah which probably
ends up not being true yeah it's still
pretty horrible that's a queen before
yeah Queen before Luke c1 or something
yeah yeah we'll see if I've played DC
595 I think probably is is it yeah
because we're still losing the d5 pawn
after a bishop place B 1 so I was very
attracted to the idea of lending the
knight on his cheeks but it might not
actually happen here
DC played and yeah okay Knight takes e5
interesting so he's calculated something
here do I have a chance okay so he just
he is intending to after hope d5 I'm
sure there's some tactical something
which works I understand it's not very
specific but neither six I was even
looking at 97 96 I mean I don't want to
win that one I want to win this one but
the thing is you get 97 yeah that's
that's a very good point I mean rook FD
897 w7 I'm still pretending I'm alive
somehow enough might be 7 like I don't
know if I'm winning here but I wouldn't
be surprised if I was with white like
something like rook c2 and I think it
lands on c7 in many cases and probably
ends the game who knows but yet feels a
little bit like 25 I thought we'd take
taken taken b7 and because the poor
selected another position where there
was a queen on v7 yeah sorry you know
I'm still not sure because there's work
of six here 96 ah yeah that is that is
good that is guys the nasty yeah and
hikaru declines the invitation goes
through caffee eight that is very
surprising to me because like we know
what this position is disaster yeah oh
that guy over there is a spawn spawn
yeah
but sure we got like rook c1 c7 and
everything starts starts crumbling right
he's played rook c1 already looks quite
clean yeah we can also take on his seven
first but we don't need to yeah because
do we 95 yeah I guess we end up winning
this are we
like rugby 5 here oh I miss repeat I
repeat two maybe maybe it's still
winning but it feels it feels like
Bishop takes you seven is just cleaner
why are we why are we giving up any of
our stuff by the way when you see the
move Bishop e7 and you think about the
worst kind of Kings Indian endings where
the bishop on g7 versus a good night
yeah we could also talking about chess
sadism how about this that's how about
Thor a god of thunder how about this
yeah it's just not great no it's
bringing back is bringing back very
painful memories as I as I said wow that
would be a very very enjoyable position
for the Chinese my master time what
happen no really it's I think it's a
very decent technical solution here
honestly unless there's rook c8 there
now it works the edge work c-27 he can
still do it here it's still complete is
completely winning if he wants I don't
think anything changed
uh so oh yeah rook c2 is probably just
cleaner just go in for the kill then the
second one on c7 and win yeah no this is
just a absolutely absolutely dreadful
positional before active play yeah you
have to play four but sadly for you I
think liberating the bishop
yeah you liberate it and then it gets
captured on g7 which is party-pooper
yeah I know that bad indeed well I mean
if this position holds up you'll have
appointment with mr. ding glare in
Magnus how do you feel about them apples
it's kind of it's gonna be it's gonna be
tough obviously but I mean I always give
the same answer he's gonna be tough but
I feel good so but he's shown he's shown
in these in these tournaments and I
think especially in this match that he
he has got some serious positional
positional jobs like he can he can just
run you over with without giving you
counter chances in a lot of games so
yeah he's 66 very strong of course well
number 3 player in the world playing in
the candidates tournament to talk on the
street is which player would give you
the greatest challenge that a world
championship match might be and Engler
in were two of the biggest vote getters
so a lot of players are a lot of people
are gonna be watching your semi-final
match with with a great interest oh
sorry just resigned after yeah I think
before he gets major losses like a full
rook in most lines I think I was trying
to show the either lines while you were
you were speaking yeah it's just a
completely lost position so that was a
real disaster and there you have it the
final
or in this quarter final two and a half
half the semi-finals which will begin
tomorrow same time same channel have
been secured and we have the four
semi-finalists again
Magnus sorry you got I think he got cut
off there
have you played well no I mean of course
you played him a lot I'm just trying to
think of a man no I mean I mean the
first intentional I played against thing
I i drew the first then lost a second
and somehow won the last two
miraculously so it's obviously gonna be
tough I lost the playoff in in the same
field Cup as well I recall you playing a
big blitz rapid match in sync though Cup
were you times yeah yeah that was it
that was a really really really
fantastic demonstration but as you
pointed out the Sinquefield cut that
things went wrong there for you so I
think it all comes down to the one thing
that serve bodes well for me is that
it's a starting time right because he's
gonna be playing in in in the middle of
the night and there was this much that
we played in in blitz and rapid and it
was in 2017 in the fall and he wasn't
quite as strong than as he is now and
that much I just dominated right and
then we had the tiebreak match in the
sink field Cup which started that like
10:00 in the morning and that was just
impossible for me I mean I had no chance
no chance at 10 o'clock in the morning
and this one I guess I guess I got a
drag the matches out tried to get it to
midnight for him or even even worse
that's that's my best chance I think
your opponent is smiling since he has
joined the call as well welcome to the
show Bingley Hren and congratulations
and congratulate your your your opponent
for tomorrow underline any messages
you'd like to give to Magnus well it's a
very exciting match perhaps and just
enjoy the games excellent very happy to
play against Nalu since we play a lot of
exciting and fighting games and I hope
we can still produce many interesting
content how did you feel today things
went well for you yeah the second thing
some key points especially when I
presume they ate after that I'd found my
position much better just to walk yeah
yeah if you break in a one then a 3.93
okay five nice c4 Bishop c4 it takes and
9a - oh this is very nice
yeah [ __ ] % [ __ ] before they say what
beautiful calculation their day yeah it
should be better for what black overall
they know yeah game three was really
impressive Magnus was with us throughout
and he said you showed some positional
chops some good good understanding in
this game three even a masterclass
yes and myself a comedian anytime Magnus
felt that he had to play a six takes b5
even if it
bad position but he would really he's
thought the move Bishop f5 was a bad
boat and now I can create postpone a PC
certainly but maybe black has better
compensate counter play here compared to
the game because in the game I think in
in three moves time you're just
completely winning yeah essentially too
strong we were particularly impressed by
the move g2 g3 when it when it was shown
on the board we've got a right even
Magnus said that is the move of a
confident man at this moment about very
very good about your position yes yeah
it's very important to pretend he knows
and then you accomplish that very nicely
now Peter any questions for ding women
I think I wanted to ask if at any point
in game to let's say when when you got
to let's say this position did you feel
that Whitehead let's say if you play
slowly here do you think there might be
a chance that white holds this or yeah
15 if I didn't break through with a 5
then after 93 I don't still how to make
progress my team I played 19 to d3 but
in turn into one Bishop so in this
position let's say the King gets here
but then he still has moves to make and
there is no progress you yeah but but
after a five if fielder's there is no
there is no defense here yeah actually I
didn't see all twin if he didn't play at
five exactly this is what another point
that we were discussing that if he if he
waits here how do you foresee a sound
it's wrong
we were looking at something like just
94 93 here and no and now kind of 6 yeah
and yeah I guess I guess it always
happens somehow you can three yeah and
yes
and then we get back to what happened in
a game yeah no I don't think I have any
questions I just wanted to say extremely
well played today and congratulations
and good luck for the rest of the
tournament
absolutely and does that day there's our
social media have some questions for our
final semi-finalists are extremely happy
to have ding Liron Vedas they were
asking me already the previous
broadcaster when we will have the world
number 3 joining us so everyone is
really excited and I wanted to ask about
your experience the other day playing
banter blitz and from what I heard tens
of thousands of people were watching in
China and your your friend your
grandmaster friend was hosting it in
Chinese as well can you tell us about
that experience of course much better to
speak Chinese during the game is if I
speak English black in the first time I
played enter yeah I will only focus on
the game to say what what I will play
next and with my friend but if I connect
with a communicate with nature and there
are also many questions from the
spectators on defense then of course
also change in my native language so I
feel much relaxed when
speaking Chinese that's totally
understandable and it must have been an
amazing experience for all your fans in
China and outside China I see so many
people in the chat in english language
chat as well rooting for you
congratulations again on making it to
the semi-finals and as we announced the
Tingler ins opponent is the world
champion Magnus Carlsen starting
tomorrow
thank you Anna I think I have one final
question before I let you get to sleep
because it's a late image I know they're
for you I noticed that your country
woman who - was playing a banter blitz
we came on the show tell us your
thoughts about who he thought of course
the a chess player should very very
strong but no maybe trip in more focus
on in study but also healed social
activities may begin
not totally focused on the chest since
he had many hardest things to do I hope
she'll better get back to the tournament
yeah as do we all wish her hope she does
come back to chess
she is missed thank you very much for
joining us get yourself some sleep
you've got an important game tomorrow it
gets a good opponent thank you very much
dick bye for now
and Peter if you could sum up today well
today was a I feel a masterclass by
biting Lear and he played game one was a
very correctly played Catalan which
ended as correctly played Catalans often
do in the draw and then games two and
three I think ting played
better than Hikaru quite simply and and
very very well there were moments during
Game two where he carved me we could
have played better and maybe his
position wasn't wasn't all that bad in
parts of it but if you look at the
overall picture Jing took more precise
decisions throughout that game and
eventually his very sharp tactical
solutions and his general understanding
have prevailed in particularly if you
look at the sequence starting from
probably a somewhat optimistic move
might be to see for hereby Hikaru
allowing a four and if we look at the
position five moves later black is
suddenly winning a lot of material and
although well during the broadcast we
thought maybe black would have converted
cleaner but in the ending there and did
not really have too much trouble
dismantling this attempted fortress by
the American and then Game three to my
eyes was maybe even more impressive
because Hikaru is a very very
accomplished player of the King's Indian
and he was at least in the last ten most
he was made to look I mean his position
for looked exactly like the Kings Indian
positions aren't really supposed to look
white achieved absolutely everything on
on the Queen side without allowing any
counter play frankly on the Kings side
and this is not how I expected that game
to go when I when I saw let's say some
position remove more fifteen where it
still looked like there is plenty of
play and like has all kinds of plans to
the sharpen things up but then played
very confidently without really ever
losing control over the proceedings and
I think emerges is a very deserved
winner off today set and the the entire
match absolutely and before I set the
semi-finals match I just want to ask you
about your own professional schedule
there Peter are you going to be with us
tomorrow I think I'm not as far as as
far as I know tomorrow I'm skipping a
day and I will be able a bleary place
replaced by by Sam Shanklin so the
viewers have that to look forward to but
I will be back for much of the
conclusion of the event must keep one
more day somewhere wonderful thank you
for that Peter and Anna get the last
word from the social media crowd what
did they think of today's match and what
do you have what's trending I think
simply everyone is amazed by of course
the quality of play of the world number
3 ding glitter and lots of fans of
hikaru being said that he Carter will
not continue with us for the rest of
this event but remember guys he's doing
very well overall so he we may see him
in the next leg of the Magnus cross and
Chester and maybe even maybe even in the
grand finale so hikaru overall is still
doing very well in terms of their
standing points which we were trying to
describe earlier who are not doing very
well I was looking at our predictions
guys we were trying to predict these
pairs and from the Grigio Giri match I
was the only one who picked any so I got
that one right but between Dingley Ren
and Haku Nakamura it was only Peter who
picked England so none of us are on two
out of two I'm afraid in our little
fantasy contest doesn't sound like we're
doing well but in any case here are the
semi-finalists your semi-finalists
Magnus Carlsen versus Dane Lauren and a
yawn and nepo versus Amish Mary will be
Contessa same time same Channel looking
forward to that
those semi finals and a big shout out to
each and every one of you thank you so
much for joining us let your friends
know where you're hanging out and join
us or tomorrow in the meanwhile have a
good night bye everyone
if you're a chess player you have plenty
of opportunities to challenge and play
online against the top players
participating in the chess about masters
super tournament don't miss the
opportunity to learn from the best check
out the chess 24 shows area and tune in
for banter blitzes with the likes of
Magnus Carlsen Fabiano Cara Juana
Alexander Chris Chuck and bent Allah
Hari Krishna go premium at chess 24 to
challenge them and gain full access to
the world's most entertaining chess
platform
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
every battle is won by preparation we've
taken one of the most popular chess
books ever written and rewired it for
the modern player the art of attack
lomba chess will stay - the art move
trainer technology presented by myself
grandmaster Simon Williams I'll talk you
through twenty nine hours worth of
educational video content from attacking
the young castle King Bishop sacrifices
diagonal attacks and classic porn storms
paint your opponent's King into a corner
with the art of attack hello this is
crystals alaikum and welcome to my
cupids simple 1.d4 course
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chest skills with the world champion
Magnus Carlsen
the Magnus trainer app is packed with
fun minigames an interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the Magnus trainer available in the App
Store and Google Play
[Music]
you
hello this is Chris of delegate and
welcome to my keep it simple
1e for course
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]